this video is sponsored by squarespace
almost every single self-improvement
youtuber
self-improvement book motivational
speaker will
tell you how important it is to have
confidence confidence in yourself
confidence in everything that you do
they'll also go on and on and on about
how important it is to have
high self-esteem and to feel sure about
yourself
and to know that no matter what you set
your mind to you're capable of doing it
never accept less than what you think
you're worth never stay in a job that
you don't like
don't keep doing things that you don't
truly love and as a society we just sort
of accept this advice
as if it's gospel as if there is no
downside
to this radical self-assurance but like
any philosophy
i think it's unwise to not question it
and i think that this sort of blind
optimism
is worth questioning in fact i think
it's the very reason why so many people
feel so stuck in life
because one of the main downsides to
this unconditional
self-confidence in everything that you
do is that it can quickly turn
into an inflated sense of what we're
capable of which blinds us from
correcting our weaknesses
changing paths if something's not
working and that can
really prevent us from improving our
lives or making
progress in any substantial way because
there's a word for an inflated sense of
self-confidence
one that's beyond the realm of reality
we call that
ego you know if when your sense of your
own capabilities and importance in life
is bigger than reality itself it's
called having a big ego
and sometimes having a big ego is really
difficult to spot
i know for a fact it was in my own life
i've talked a lot on this channel about
how when i went to university
it wasn't a filmmaking specific
university so in my intro level film
classes
i was the best filmmaker in the room or
so i thought but as soon as somebody in
the class had a film that maybe they put
more effort into than i did
i felt threatened by this and i was in
denial i started looking for faults in
their work and there's no way that they
know how to work a camera or have better
cinematography than i do
and that blinded myself from my own
weaknesses in my work
you know i was living in this sort of
fantasy land where i'm this master
filmmaker
even though i'm not even close to being
that and i knew i wasn't
but my ego was blinding me from the
reality it was blinding me from my
weaknesses and things that i needed to
work on
which prevented me from reaching the
goal of actually becoming a masterful
filmmaker
a goal which i'm nowhere near
accomplishing your ego is kind of
addicting
it tells you all the nice things that
you want to hear it tells you how good
and special and talented you are but it
doesn't really help you improve
you know your ego is different from
confidence because
confidence stems from competence as you
get better at things you develop a track
record of being competent at that thing
so that you know for a fact that you can
pull this off
you're capable of doing this that's
confidence you gain confidence through
repetition and mastery your ego tells
you that you're talented and special and
you can
you can do whatever you want to do but
it's not actually grounded in a track
record of success
i think one of the most common examples
of people's ego
getting in the way of their success is
when they're working a job that they
feel like they're better than maybe it's
an entry-level position
maybe they're working at a fast food
restaurant they're flipping burgers
and they have an undergraduate degree
and they're super educated in some field
yet they still find themselves stuck in
entry-level jobs
and they start thinking to themselves
what am i doing here i'm better than
this i'm more educated than all of my
peers
i deserve better a lot of the time
that's just your ego talking
it's blinding you from the reality that
perhaps your resume isn't that
impressive
to the employers in the field that you
want to go into perhaps you should
accept the loss of time
in whatever degree you got or whatever
jobs you're working before
take a slice of humble pie and figure
out the best way forward from an
objective perspective
no matter how unflattering that path
might look on the surface level
our ego blinds us from reality and if we
can't accept reality we can't improve it
in the book ego is the enemy by ryan
holiday he talks about how you can
aspire to be either one of two things
you can aspire to be somebody or you can
aspire to do something
and he argues that we live in a world
filled with people trying to be
somebody in fact you're kind of told
that your whole life go out there and be
somebody so naturally people want to get
their lucky break
they want to be recognized as special
they want to work their way up in the
company so that they can eventually
sit at the big desk with the big boys if
you're an artist you really want to be
recognized for your talent
you know get your lucky break become
famous you know and everybody wants to
be
an instagram influencer or a tick-tock
star or a youtuber they want to have
millions of people recognizing how
special they are they want to be
somebody they want to have
influence that's the more tempting
option the other option is to aspire to
do
something to get something done to have
a purpose or a mission
doing the best you can do in your craft
this type of person is a lot more
concerned about
action and education rather than
validation
and status the person who aspires to do
something in life
is a lot more concerned with being
useful rather than
appearing to be useful or looking busy
this is especially relevant
for artists and creatives if you're an
influencer or a youtuber i think you
really need to hear this as well
if your video if your art if your craft
whatever it is
is good enough it's its own marketing
you know if you
double down and put in 10 times more
effort into your next video
if you put in 10 times more effort into
your next art piece
then the work will kind of speak for
itself you know there's a higher chance
that it'll become extremely useful to
people
and then the word of mouth effect will
start to take place you know every
single time that i start to get caught
up with how special i am for having
almost a million subscribers and how i'm
a big youtuber and all my videos get
lots of views
as soon as i start thinking that way i
start focusing on the wrong things
my videos start to suffer you know the
actual quality of the videos and the
message starts to suffer dramatically
the best videos i've ever made the ones
i'm super proud of
are videos where i was just really
concerned with
telling the best story or getting my
message across
in the best way possible in the most
effective way possible
i treated the video in and of itself as
the end goal and whether or not that
video blows up in the algorithm is kind
of irrelevant
because i became that much better as a
filmmaker and a storyteller and
my existing audience takes notice of
that and they really appreciate it
and when you offer that much value to
people and you're that useful to people
everything sort of comes into alignment
the views and the subscribers and the
comments and the likes
they all kind of take care of themselves
so i guess what i'm trying to get at
with this video is
no matter what you're into no matter
what your profession or your hobby or
your craft is
you need to take on the role of a
student every single person wants to be
noticed and respected but i think the
path forward to dramatic progress in
your life
is the willingness to become a nobody
until your results
put you in a different category you know
if you're applying for a job
how much better would it be if your
resume was three
times better than anyone else's not from
a formatting perspective
not from you using fluffy language to
describe yourself
but by you being three times more
qualified
experienced educated than anybody else
applying for that same job stop caring
so much about what other people think
about you
how you appear in the world and actually
be someone who is useful to people
so useful that not having you in the
room or part of the team
or the company is such an immediate and
dramatic
detriment to everyone around you that
they have no choice but to always have
you around
because you're that useful i guess if i
was to distill this entire video down
into just a couple of sentences
a little recap it would be that no
matter where you are in life
if you've experienced a lot of success
and you're still
unfulfilled and you feel like you're
kind of a house of cards waiting to fall
down
or maybe you haven't experienced a lot
of success in your life at all
and you feel stuck pay attention to your
ego pay attention to what this little
sinister voice in the back of your head
is telling you
is it telling you you're too good for
this you're already the best and you
can't improve
because that's all kind of [ __ ]
strip away the ego
try to view your position with a
ruthless objectivity
and honesty and doing that will reveal a
path forward and no matter how painful
that path forward may seem
no matter how embarrassing it might look
see what happens if you take it
because going down that unflattering
path
may be the answer to all your problems
this video was sponsored by squarespace
and i'm really excited that i'm
partnering with squarespace for this
video because i'm actually using
squarespace
currently to build my new website and
what i'm finding
is the same thing that i always find
with squarespace is that not only are
there drag and drop templates extremely
easy to use
but their stuff just looks aesthetically
better than any other website builder
out there it's sleek
it's modern it's professional it's
exactly what i'm looking for and i'm
sure you guys would agree
if you're someone like me and you've
been thinking about business ideas
chronically for your entire life and
you're waiting for that perfect day to
start one
then there's no better place to start
than to build a website using
squarespace
and on that note if you are using
squarespace to sell digital or physical
products
there's so many modern day payment
integrations that they've implemented
you can charge your customers or clients
using stripe
venmo paypal apple pay there's so many
different options to
get that sweet sweet dough and earn
financial freedom and if you use my link
in the description below you'll get 10
off your first order but you can
obviously just click the link and you
don't have to pay anything to play
around with their templates to sort of
get a vibe for your first website just
make sure that you use the code
better ideas at checkout when you do
eventually pay to launch that awesome
website so make sure you take advantage
of that offer
click the link in the description below
cop that 10 percent off
launch your website make your presence
known on the internet
and as usual have a great time if you
liked this video
make sure you hit like because when you
hit like the algorithm
it blesses me and it shoves my bald head
into other people's home pages helping
them out
which also helps me out so it's a
win-win for everybody
if you're lurking here and this is the
thousandth perhaps even millionth time
you've seen my head
make sure you not only hit subscribe but
you hit the bell icon
so that you don't miss future videos
it's kind of a crazy weekend
i don't want to get into details but i
really wanted to put in more effort to
editing it and actually shooting some
b-roll for this video
wasn't able to but i guess we can save
it for next video there's two videos
coming out in december
thank you so much for watching as usual
and we'll catch you the next video
also yeah i'm going to shave this
mustache off it's not good